في مشهد مؤثر قام اب جزائري بانقاذ زوجته
واولاده من وسط فيضانات قويه جرفت سيارتهم
واظهر الفيديو شجاعه الرجل الذي امسك
بزوجته واولاده بيده وقام باخراجهم الى
حافه الطريق حتى جاءت السلطات لانقاذهم
[موسيقى]
بعد ان تحولت مياه مدينه البندقيه في
ايطاليا الى اللون الاخضر الفاقع زادت
التكهنات حول الحادثه وفي النهايه ذكرت
السلطات الايطاليه ان ما حدث هو خدعه من
النشطاء البيئه لتوعيه بخطر تلوث المئه
[موسيقى]
في ظاهره فلكيه لافته اختفى ظل الكعبه
المشرفه في مكه المكرمه بسبب تعامد الشمس
مع الكعبه هذه الظاهره تتكرر مرتين كل عام
وكان قديما التعامد التعامد وسيله لتحديد
اتجاه القبله
بضحكه واسعه وفرحه عارمه استطاع طفل ليبي
ان يخطف القلوب ويتصدر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي حيث ظهر في صوره ومقطع فيديو
وهو سعيد جدا استاذ زملائه من حفل انتهاء
الدراسه وبدء العطله الصيفيه
[موسيقى]
تحولت امراه تايلانديه الى مليونيره بين
عشيه وضحاها بعدما عثرت على كنز في وجبه
العشاء التي كانت تعدها لزوجها وبحسب ما
افادت وسائل اعلام فقد عثرت السيده على
لؤلؤه النادره داخل محاره كبيره اشترتها
من سوق محلي وبعد قيامها بتنظيفها وتحضير
الوجبه جلست لتتناول العشاء مع زوجها الذي
شعر فجاه بجسم صلب في فمه ظن انه حجر لكنه
ادرك مع زوجته انهما عثره على لؤلؤه ميلو
البرتقاليه باهظه الثمن
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات